[Music]
beauty is in the eye of the beholder but
not when it comes to these animals we've
uncovered some of the creepiest
creatures on the planet that have a face
only a mother could love
but as unattractive as these animals are
there's something about them that makes
them oh so cute if you're new to our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we'll be showing you ten things
that are cute but creepy at the same
time just wait until you see the
pictures of the tarsier it's so
cringe-worthy but it'll make you say ahh
at the same time baby aardvarks we had
to start off this video with one of the
creepiest animals our eyes have ever
seen this right here is called a baby
aardvark and it looks like something
that came straight out of a sci-fi movie
this nocturnal mammal is most commonly
found in sub-saharan Africa but you
might be able to find one at your local
zoo too they have a pretty creepy
appearance don't you think just check
out their elongated heads their noses
that look a lot like a pig snout their
large floppy ears wrinkled skin and
they're really thick necks despite
looking like something that would pop up
in one of our nightmares the aardvark is
so creepy that it's cute at the same
time the animals appearance changes a
lot within the first few weeks after its
birth but it doesn't get any better
appearance wise when they become adults
either sadly this animal remains on most
web sites ugly lists for the majority of
its life do you think the aardvark is
one of the cutest yet creepiest animals
you've ever seen and forward tamarin
monkey how adorable is this tiny little
monkey it's called an Emperor tamarin
and it can primarily be found in South
and Central America the animal was named
after German emperor William ii who had
a pretty impressive handlebar moustache
although we would get completely creeped
out if we stumbled across a monkey with
this kind of facial hair we can't help
but think the tamarin is the cutest
little animal we've ever seen their fur
is mainly black and gray and they have a
reddish tail but it's their snow-white
mustaches that people just can't get
enough of the total population of this
creepy animal has declined in recent
years due to deforestation and hunting
people are now aiming to capture the
monkeys who sell them as pets although
we can see the appeal of having one of
these cute yet creepy animals of the
household pet they're better left living
in their natural habitat in the wild can
you imagine waking up in the middle of
the night and seeing your
mustache wearing monkeys staring right
at you yeah neither could we talk about
creepy flowerhorn fish we bet you've
never seen anything quite like this this
fish is called the flower horn the
species is able to mate with other
flower horns and with completely
different fish types - this is why there
are so many different variations of fish
in the world and many of them have a
rather unusual appearance some breeds
even change color during their lifetime
going from black to a beautiful color
like yellow or red the vibrant and
bright colors are the first things
people notice but if you take a closer
look you'll notice its appearance is
pretty shocking - they have a big and
bulky body fan-shaped fins and a big
colorful hump on the top of their
forehead the humps are found in both
male and female flower horns but it's
much bigger and more noticeable in the
males and look at their cute little
mouths and plump lips they're definitely
giving kylie jenner a run for her money
what do you think about the flower horn
fish is it creepy or cute giant African
bullfrog we're sure you've seen a
bullfrog before but we bet you've never
seen one as cute as this one it's called
the giant African bullfrog and just as
its name suggests it can be found in
central and southern Africa its bodies
covered in long ridges and it has a
pretty massive head the male frogs can
reach up to 9 inches in length and they
have an average weight of 3 pounds
that's a pretty big frog this bullfrog
is considered an exotic pet and when
it's raised in captivity it can live for
up to 35 years it would make a pretty
loyal companion although we just can't
get over how creepy and slimy it looks
one thing is sure this frog is pretty
photogenic just check out this picture
of an African bullfrog giving the camera
a nice big smile you can imagine this
frog looks good from any angle and it's
definitely not camera shy does this frog
creep you out or do you think it's
adorable let us know your answer down
below in the comment section and you
might even get a reply from us aye-aye
yikes this frightening little creature
is definitely a bit terrifying it's
called an aye-aye and we don't know
whether we should grab it and rock it to
sleep like a baby or run away from it
while screaming our heads off this
menacing yet sweet looking creature can
be found on the island of Madagascar and
its appearance it's a bit ghoulish the
aye-aye has dark brown and black fur and
it's big and bushy tail is longer than
its entire body it also has a set of
really big eyes and long slender fingers
that are attached to some pointy claws
but if you want to get your hands on one
of these furry creatures a good luck
they spend most of the day curled up in
a ball on top of the highest trees even
when they wake up during the night to
roam around for food they hardly even
make their way down to the ground they
stay inside the trees of the forest and
search for insects underneath the bark
maybe it's a good thing most people will
never come in contact with the aye-aye
as cute as they look we can't help but
think they're just a tad bit creepy
looking to thornback ray there are two
sides to the thorn back raid the creepy
side and the incredibly cute side the
creepy side is definitely the top
portion of this species it looks like
your typical stingray with its flattened
body and long wing-like fins its tail
and back are covered in a bunch of
thorny spines the top of the ray berries
in color from light brown to gray and
some even have yellow patches on their
skin when they're threatened by other
sea life their bodies can appear to turn
black pretty scary right
but it's the bottom part of the
thornback ray that make them so adorable
they have a translucent body slits that
look like eyes and just check out the
smile on the storm backs phase doesn't
it look like he's saying cheese for the
camera
the thornback may look menacing from the
top part of its body but the bottom part
of them just warms our hearts it looks
so innocent and loveable even though we
know their body is covered in a hundreds
of spiky thorns that can really do some
damage baby Spanx this may look like a
species from another planet but it's
actually a feline called a baby's fangs
this species of hairless cat were
created through a selective breeding
process starting back in the 1960s even
though they look out of this world this
creepy creature is a pretty popular
household pet their price tag can reach
thousands of dollars but according to
pet owners they're worth every penny
some Sphinx cats have whiskers while
others don't but they have all of the
typical markings of regular cats without
any hair on their bodies you can see
every feature of this animal from its
wedge-shaped head large eyes pointy ears
and their high and prominent cheekbones
their skin is the colour their fur would
be and since they are hairless they can
get pretty cold very fast that's why
this Finks makes a great pet it
definitely won't run and hide when you
pull it in for some cuddles
they love any activity that will warm
them up would you love to be the proud
owner of a hairless cat like the sphinx
let us know your answer down below in
the comment section
we can't wait to
read your reply proposes monkey there
are over 260 types of monkeys in the
world and this one just might be the
strangest-looking of them all it's
called a proboscis and it primarily
lives in the jungles of Borneo when you
first take a look at this monkey doesn't
kind of look like an older man we think
so this monkey is well known for its
facial features especially its nose it's
unusually large and hangs down from its
face sort of like a banana it has eyes
that are similarly shaped like human
eyes a slit for a mouth and an entire
body covered in orange and reddish-brown
hair he also has a funny bulging
potbelly and makes it look like this
monkey may have drank one too many beers
the Provos estefy isn't winning any
beauty pageants in the wilderness but
we're sure they don't mind they dominate
the wildlife in Borneo with their
massive size they are one of the largest
monkey species in Asia and they can
weigh up to 50 pounds and they stand at
about 28 inches tall what would you do
if you ever came in contact with this
peculiar looking animal tars here if
you've just screamed out what the heck
is that don't worry you're not the only
one this animal has the ability to give
anyone the heebie-jeebies just by gazing
into its eyes it's called the tarsier
and as you can see it is a tiny creature
with a massive eyes each eyeball is a
little more than half an inch in
diameter and each eye is as large as the
tarsiers entire brain just imagine if
humans had eyes larger than their brains
those would be some pretty gigantic eyes
the tarsiers body is about 5 inches in
length and their tails are about 9
inches long this animal is the nocturnal
species so they're extra big eyes
definitely come in handy when it's time
for them to search for their food but
because their eyes are so big they can't
rotate them at all they have to turn
their heads and move their necks when
they want to scope out the scene this is
why their necks can rotate 180 degrees
in every direction just like owls this
allows them to sit in silence and
observe their prey from a distance and
spot them from all directions before
they pounce smiling salamander check out
this cute little creature
this is a rare axolotl salamander also
known as the smiling salamander can you
guess why it was given this nickname
it's because of the adorable smile on
its face of course this amphibian can be
found at aquariums and other aquatic
parks and as I'm sure you can guess it's
a favorite amongst the visit
the salamander is unique because it has
the ability to regenerate its body parts
over time this means it can regrow
entire limbs and its major organs - it
has a very wide head and eyes with no
lids and they have a pair of external
gills that raise up from their bodies
like long stalks they look pretty creepy
don't you think if you dream of seeing a
smiling salamander in the wild with your
own two eyes you may have trouble
locating one they reside in a lake in
Mexico City and the entire population
has practically been wiped out due to
pollution and because the salamander is
considered a delicacy in some countries
which of these creepy animals is the
cutest to you let us know your pick down
below in the comment section if you
enjoyed this video and would love to see
more just like it please give us a big
thumbs up and subscribe to our Channel
thanks for watching
[Music]